los servicios de inteligencia
internacional siempre lo han denominado
como una de las cabezas más importantes
del programa nuclear de hecho lo
vinculan con los años antes del año 2000
cuando se dice que irán estaba
investigando para desarrollar armas
nucleares un programa que habría
desmantelado alrededor del año 2003 a él
se le asigna haber estado a la cabeza de
ese programa como decía y por esas
razones fue sancionado por las naciones
unidas irán siempre ha negado que él
está involucrado con el programa nuclear
está vinculado con el ministerio de
defensa como decían hoy que hacía parte
del departamento de investigación pero
además se dice que es un guardia
revolucionario es un brigadier general
una figura muy importante y de ahí la
muestra también que tuviera ese ese
equipo de seguridad con él algo que no
es muy frecuente dentro de la mayoría de
las autoridades iraníes